hey y'all it's ginger memes hey guys
what's up it's your girl ziggly caliente
hi everyone i'm jan
hi everybody it's eureka here you found
it hi
class i'm a curious chanel davenport hi
i'm supernut mackinac hi i'm pandorabox
hi is bro didn't be here what up though
it's your home garage
hello it's the cha cha cha cha hey
queens
it's kylie sonique love let's meet your
dk renee from all star season six
and today we're here with buzzfeed to
play a little game of
who's who who's the most likely to read
anyone to fill jiggly jiggly
jiggly walks in the room reading okay
but that's how she shows that it'd be
like we gotta talk
like you did something wrong that's the
shadiest i know
i always say what i'm thinking even if i
don't mean it to be shady it'll just
i don't know why it just comes out shady
it's not my fault she reads me to phil
all the time she will call me she's like
what are you doing oh i'm just driving
to the grocery store
do you need to go to the grocery store
you're already bad enough
okay maybe not exactly that way but oh
okay sorry
do you need to go to the grocery store
you already said enough
is that better
i said jiggly oh tea i said it curious
i said raja jiggly eureka
trinity is like you know she'll tell you
how it is pearl she'll give you
the true tea jiggly i think she uh
enjoys it
kicked out of reading people and making
herself laugh
and i picked eureka because she's like
the disney blonde white girl that we
read and don't even realize she'll be
reading
i might have to change my answer to
jigglypuff a little peer pressure goes a
long way i've known her for a long time
and it's absolutely true who's most
likely to borrow
a piece of clothing in the work room
trinity
me i'm insane that's the toss-up between
trinity and kylie is what i heard
uh-huh because we like fashion if you've
got something that's cute like we could
all trade
though we're all small i said raja just
cuz the whole wigs thing you know she
said
the wig like i have made it into herself
oh oh i haven't i have one kylie
oh kylie is so a kylie thing she's
always like let me get your scraps for
the craft project she's like okay
i always need a little something are you
gonna use this girl hey miss eureka do
you have a big pair of
earrings i can wear for this runway girl
me
no i never borrow clothes hair
jewelry yes clothes i can never fit
because
i'm wide but i'm also very very short
where's my red dress ginger
you should have got your red dress i
left it and for the record
you made me put on that dress i twisted
your arm jinder
she's the type of person that'll look
around the work room and go mind if i
borrow that and then she'll go borrow
another little piece from somebody else
and then she puts it together and looks
gorgeous makes me kind of mad because
she looks perfect in everything
me trinity did borrow things
everything she had was borrowed who's
most likely to have the messiest
workstation
at any given time i wasn't paying
attention to
you know myself honey it was mentioned
to me a few times
from the lady that i shared a
workstation with that we were not in
college
i could like you know get my [ __ ]
together and like
fine then i vote for scarlet girl i'm
just like a stoner i don't know what you
want me to say
scarlett and cali both i don't know what
it is they are the glam
highly yeah the turn kylie both like
it's as soon as they start getting ready
they're
ends up everywhere and they were right
beside each other too and they were
right beside me
so i'm just going to call them out on it
do you remember that one day whenever my
nails were on the station i had the glue
dots on it and somebody had put their
stuff on them and i flipped out about it
yeah it was totally solid suitcase
that's when i told her i said
this ain't college no more mistakes
i was kind of
actually you know what garlic's messy
too i was like
oh okay it was literally me
scarlet and silky right next to each
other it looked like a tornado had went
through
cookie's always missing something so i
was like oh yeah silky
i say me because i i'm very much him an
artist
in the sense that i try to create beauty
from chaos
i just dump my makeup bag out it's fun
for all involved
which two queens are most likely to
become the next iconic drag race
duo and serena and sulky
me and phil and yar and serena
i feel like they hang out a lot
definitely a curious silkie
of course i mean for obvious reasons we
have natural chemistry we've always
known each other for years but we've got
really close season 11. she's like a bad
hemorrhoid it just would not go away
me and ginger me and mrs jigglesworth we
we are
already an iconic duo we have a cooking
show
that we started on youtube it's now
moving into a real season
on out tv called wigs in a blanket we
have two songs together
we do have a song together called chub
love
we love to work together we work well
together
she's an idiot and i have a loud mouth
me and roger we got this
girl you and y'all i can see that yeah
although we don't get along at all
me and yara because i think i was the
only one that understood what she's
saying
all the time who's most likely to be
crying backstage
dan oh jan but the thing is janet's
gonna be like crying but like
i'm okay it's great everything's great
but full-on tears coming down her face
bye girl oh great oh i love you jen i
love it when you get emotional
me too somebody tells me like a
heartwarming servant
we wear our enlarged hearts on our
sleeves well i spent so many years like
trying to hold it back and hold it in
and
not let it out into the world but now it
just comes naturally
i watched like reading card commercials
and i was sobbing mess for two days
ginger yara we all said something
different
i said yara because i feel like she's
just like very raw i mean who doesn't
love a good cry
honestly i need one right now do you
mind who's most likely to get ready the
fastest
looking flaw free raja she definitely
probably get ready fastest yeah
hilariously quick i'm painting an
eyebrow she's done and
lovely you know jinger's always like
tries to be ready first but honey raja
would always beat her to the punch
raja none of these girls get ready quick
this is raja gets ready quick out of all
of us
she paints the fastest i paint the
fastest but i'm not flaw free
um so i can't raja would have to be the
closest to that but even still she
doesn't get ready that quickly
granted we're all drag queens so getting
ready for stage is at least a two hour
mark
she's maybe like five minutes faster
than the rest of us thanks for watching
y'all and you can check us out on all
star six premiering on paramount plus
on june 24th let the gangs begin
you